it's such a weird way to display your
life because it's you know you're
displaying the best aspects of your life
and some sort of a glass
case
you know it's just it's an unrealistic
version of your life that you cultivate
and you curate and i'm i'm as guilty of
that as anybody everybody's guilty of it
i'm guilty of it too yeah you know i
mean i pose with my dog every time i run
yeah we're always signaling yeah it's
like rather than really looking at
yourself you're looking at how other
people look at you so it's like this one
remove mental image and it's kind of a
disease because social media is making
celebrities of all of us and celebrities
the most miserable people in the world
right because they're this strong
self-image that gets built up it gets
built up by compliments every time
somebody pays you or me a compliment and
we're like oh well thank you right then
that builds up an image of who we are
and then one idiot comes along one out
of ten one out of 100 and they can
easily tear it down because it doesn't
take many insults to cancel out a lot of
compliments and now you're carrying
around this big weighty self image and
it's just very easy to be attacked and
because you're you're famous or you're
well known people want to attack you so
being a celebrity is no good it's
actually a problem like one of my tweets
is and these are all reminders to myself
is you want to be rich and anonymous not
poor and famous
right how do you learn to not care about
what other people think of you
um this is a hard one and this is what
i'm screwing up right now
the way to forget the insults is to not
take in the compliments in the first
place
because when someone insults you
for that insult to affect you
it has to hit in self-image that you
have created and that self-image was
created through compliments
and through as a kind of a defense
mechanism so
if you can avoid getting happy
this is obviously hard but if you can
get avoid being happy
when somebody
compliments you then you won't be as
insulted when they insult you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you